[Applause]
California
[Applause]
all right
happy Tuesday everyone it's my favorite
day of the week except for all the
others
Jimmy phela is here
yeah
you don't have to clap
oh he brought his jacket there it is
must have been an estate sale hey so as
you know talking about a stolen election
can get you into trouble it's the
equivalent of shouting fire in a crowded
theater except you can actually shout
fire in a crowded theater especially if
there's a fire and you started it
even more if you're a Democrat and
you're about to become White House Press
Secretary something tells me you'll get
a pass on this Karen Jean-Pierre sounds
like the goalie for the Montreal
Canadiens
is that a real team well anyway she's
been tapped to replace Jen sackey but
did you know she once falsely claimed
that the 2018 Georgia gubernatorial
election was actually stolen I know
since when do Democrats care about theft
but I get it when someone gets a fancy
job embarrassing tweets surfaced like a
bloated corpse in the East River I
remember when this show started someone
started leaking these erotic videos I
had made back when I needed the money
true I was the one leaking them
I just felt they needed a wider audience
but jean-pierre's tweet matters because
that sort of thing would disqualify
anyone who isn't a lefty back on April
2nd 2020 she tweeted reminder Brian Kemp
stole the gubernatorial election from
Georgians and Stacy Abrams of course no
Dam has called this an attack on
Democracy a claim they're always making
against Republicans but they would know
democracy if it bit him in their elitist
butts but she's merely echoing exactly
what the dams getaway was saying already
which tells you it's only a crime if a
republican does it you know like
marrying your brother
foreign
who hasn't
you've married a lot yeah well maybe
only once never mind you haven't heard
much of it but Stacy Abrams filed a
federal lawsuit over Georgia's
management of Elections and the trial
actually began last month you could say
the lawsuit said attempt to undermine
the Integrity of Georgia elections but
like a Plane full of passengers during
the safety demonstration no one's
listening they're too busy trying to
find gas and baby formula which causes
gas
anyway because she said damn that stuff
doesn't matter mainly because the Press
is on her side they go together like
peanut butter and jelly pizza and beer
and nipple clamps and cheese whiz
and they want elections as secure as the
Border think about that now as you know
saki's leaving her job to go to work at
MSNBC so she can now lie while sitting
down
now if you don't know the network it's
the news station that makes the weekly
world news look like Face the Nation but
I guess someone has to do the work they
pay Rachel Maddow for
anyway I want her job I don't know if
she's got a show coming her way but I
hear that her office duties will involve
feeding Joy Reed and changing Lawrence
O'Donnell half the duties she performed
for Biden
I just hope Jen enjoys her first day at
MSNBC
Jen welcome aboard hope you're getting
settled in let me know if you need
anything office supplies or whatever
well the supply chain is a top priority
for the Biden Administration that's why
he's working with all of our Global
Partners to ensure a strong economy I
was talking about like Staples or pens
or anything anyway make yourself at home
let me know if anything
foreign
President Biden believes that every
American deserves to feel at home in
their own country
um no you're not um press secretary
anymore right
no more questions at this time
that isn't uh that one tweet isn't the
only thing to erupt from uh Jen's
replacement there's this video from
MSNBC where she describes Fox News as
racist back in March 2020 which she then
shared from her Twitter account
Fox News was racist before coronavirus
they are racist during the coronavirus
Fox News will be racist after the
coronavirus so there is nothing new here
I think the difference is is they have
been they are all in on being State TV
for Donald Trump and so they will
continue to give them misinformation the
danger is so yes you have Asian
Americans right now whose lives are
seriously in danger
well at least you didn't parody Mary
Poppins
remember those days you know when the
left actually did care about Asian
Americans not so much anymore now that
Asian hate crimes erupted and the
culprits aren't in Maga hats why bother
reporting them at all so as part of her
new job she'll be dealing with all of
these racist Fox news reporters
especially our own Dom SOB Peter Ducey
oh he's so racist
it's funny saki's scheduled to leave her
job Friday where she will end up right
where her replacement was when she said
we were all racist I call it the circle
of strife
like Shemp and curly they just switched
roles
Stooges reference cat
but I guess that's what Democrats mean
by both sides so with the new face of
the administration face questions about
her hatred for Fox News maybe but only
from people at Fox News assaults on the
Press are another one of those things
that can only come from Republicans but
I should point out we're not racists
we're just kicking all of their asses
and they're out of ideas so that's why
they call us racist and as long as
you're on the right side meaning the
left side you can say anything you want
but unlike the left we won't try to stop
you it's the best way to make you look
stupid
information laundering is really quite
ferocious it's when a hopster takes some
lies and makes them sounds precocious by
seeing them in Congress or a mainstream
Outlet so disinformations Origins are
slightly less atrocious
it's how you hide a delighted lie it's
how you hide a little idle lie
let's welcome
to guess
his audiences rushed the stage because
they think there's an exit behind it Fox
Across America host Jimmy phela
she's put more people in stitches than
the town stabber comedian in podcast
host Chrissy Mayer
[Applause]
The Dirty Dozen is what her podiatrist
calls her time
his 12 toes adorable filthy Fox News
contributor captain
and he bumped his head on the
International Space Station my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Television
Champion in New York that's a seller
Jimmy welcome to the show I think people
are tired of my jokes about your jackets
is that true I think so those are very
tepid response today makes me feel very
bad maybe it's the audience
are you guys profile what's going on
here
[Applause]
's the problem with being a leftist
sooner or later you're going to run into
people that you called racist because
you called everybody racist oh it's
excited she didn't think that at some
point she's gonna be in a room with
people that are like she's gonna have to
say oh hi well a couple of things first
of all on the Joy Reed Show you have to
call people racist to get in right now a
comedy club is like a two drink minimum
yeah the Joy Reid shows the cable news
equivalent of those guys outside Port
Authority that call everybody honkies
you know what I mean it becomes funny
like you go back you're like hey can you
call my kid a cracker this would be
amazing but it's funny that it came back
to her in this way this soon
um but I think the whole thing is so it
like so exposes the fraud of what they
do because people have tuned it out now
they don't care that it's racist you
know you're saying people are sick of me
and you feuding about fashion the people
are sick of being told things are racist
that clearly aren't racist she was
calling Fox races because why homeless
people were throwing Asian people in
front of trains last I checked homeless
people weren't watching uh cable news in
the Penn Station men's room right and to
the point of us calling a truce we have
and I'm going to congratulate you a lot
of people don't know this Greg just got
a role in a new Mission Impossible uh
the mission is to get something off the
top shelf
um
but but we have signed the truth
yo
Chrissy I think Jimmy makes a good point
that when you start calling everybody
racist real racist like him
I feel insulted I mean he puts all this
work into becoming a bigot and then
everybody else gets the credit it's not
fair uh like Fox is totally not racist
and I don't think it's racist at all in
the beginning of the pandemic people
were calling the the coronavirus the
China virus I don't think it's racist at
all to know where your viruses are
coming from like I know for me
personally they usually come from New
Jersey or Long Island
solid it's funny you know what I would
just add to that really quick yes if
we're racist as a network we're so bad
at it like Let me Give an example last
Thursday okay I did Harris Faulkner show
right black host okay Saturday night I
did Lawrence Jones's show black host
Saturday Sunday I did the big Saturday
big Sunday with gianno Kobo black host
Monday I was on your show with Tyrus
black co-host if we're racist we suck at
it but yeah but they just throw like
there's apparently there's a typo in the
handle all the black people yeah thank
you
just like I count the flowers on his
jacket he's like the Census Bureau for
African Americans
it's also just crazy when people act
like Fox News is like one opinion right
like a lot of different people don't
work here like you're gonna you know
hear me talk about something or give
some perspective and then have Rachel
Campo stuff you say the same thing on
Fox and Friends Weekend probably not no
like a lot of different people there is
a spectrum and you're on that Spectrum
live ADHD which is close to that yeah no
but it's true it is the um it is this
whole thing where they I think because
people watch Fox News the people that
hate Fox News watch just the clips that
are sent out by CNN
but which is what we do to CNN
I don't know we've got a CNN clip I'd be
fine with it at this point because like
six people would see it yes so they
could fire away
[Laughter]
what do you I mean what do you think
about just that I I care about it
did you not have a job should she not
should she not have that job well didn't
uh Anthony scaramucci say some colorful
things that he lasted what seven minutes
yeah that was like a new record because
of the things he said in the past were
kind of similar when he called the
reporter when he was wasted yes yeah and
I don't know as a drunk phone call worse
than saying an entire network of people
with thousands of workers are all racist
depends on the call yeah
that's what you're called but you know
it just goes back to and and this is
something that I learned a long time ago
anytime you're in an argument with
someone and you win the argument they go
to that the Panic bag right and you
start hitting them with facts and truths
you start winning the argument they have
to play the race card or the sex card or
try to bring up something that you did
months ago to win the argument well fox
has been winning the argument
for quite a some fun time so when they
get on TV and they say fox is racist
they hope that gets attention and maybe
we'll punch down yeah which you kind of
made us all do right now you elevate the
conflict
we're all punching down we're all
talking to the her and the 27 people
that watch him as if you see and now
they're like see we're in the fight we
got a chance we just need to ignore him
I mean she should she has no business if
she feels if she's that biased towards
want the news network then why are you
talking to him I would honestly he's
right a thousand percent if I was Biden
I would replace my press secretary with
a magic eight ball the problem is Hunter
might bring the wrong eight ball yes
well is it every eight ball a magic
eight ball hey girl all right you could
tell it was a slow news day
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else